احتفل وأغير وجهات
نظر الجمال الأفريقي خطوة واحدة في كل مرة
[موسيقى]
مثل تجول
اسمي تاندي روميرو وأنا صانع تغيير
المطبوعات الرائعة والتصميمات
التي أصبحت 10 دولارات أمريكية.  حققت العلامة التجارية
نجاحها في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، فأنا أحب استخدام الأشياء اليومية في
المنازل الأفريقية وتحويلها إلى
قطع فنية ، لذلك يمكن أن يكون أي شيء
سواء كنت لا أعرف الأوتاد
التي تعلق بها ملابسك في السلال
التي تستخدمها لتخزين ملابسك.  الأشياء التي
استخدمتها الحلوى لشرب المشروبات الغازية الخاصة بك في
الأشياء التي نتفاعل معها
يوميًا ككينيين أو أفارقة أحب
جمعها وتحويلها إلى
قطع أزياء والاحتفال بتراثنا
لهم ، أحب استخدام النماذج التي لها
ميزات أفريقية فريدة  لذا ، سواء
كانت فجوة في الأسنان أو أنف أكبر قليلاً
أو بينال هي مجرد الأشياء
التي ننظر إليها ونعلم أنه
يجب أن يكون أفريقيًا أعتقد أنني
متحمس حقًا للاحتفال
بلون بشرتنا وأريد غامقًا  عارضات
البطة جميلة بالنسبة لي وأريد أن أنقل
هذه الرسالة في عملي ، أبطال 2008
تنوع أمام وخلف العدسة
من التجربة
فهي تعرف مدى صعوبة أن تنجح
كامرأة في  الصناعة ، كم عدد
المصورات الكينية
البارزة هناك ، أود أن أقول الآن فقط اثنتان أو
ثلاث ، وآمل أنه سيكون من
الجيد أن تأتي بعض النساء في
هذه الصناعة التي يسيطر عليها الذكور ،
ولا ينبغي أن أعتمد على ساندي كانت شغوفة  حول
تمهيد الطريق للأجيال القادمة من
المبدعين بسبب التحديات التي
واجهتها في رحلتي الخاصة. كيف أعيد الجميل
للجيل القادم من المصورين
الذي أعتقد
أنه أعلمني أن القصص التي أدركت أنها
قوية ، وهاتان الطريقتان اللتان يمكنك
تعليمهما بإمكاني أن أقول
تمنح قصتي وقصتي الأمل لأي شخص يريد أن يكون
مصورًا فوتوغرافيًا في يوم من الأيام عندما
يكبر وأعتقد أن الطريقة الثانية هي أن أقوم بعقد
ورش عمل لأنني أريد المعلومات
التي كافحت للعثور عليها لتكون في
متناول الجيل التالي بسهولة.
صحيح ، إنه يريد الانتقال بعد ذلك في
الواقع كما لو كان يعمل
[موسيقى]